Leo has four thousand five hundred
twenty two dollars and eight cents in
his bank account he deposits another
eight hundred seventy-five dollars and
fifty cents and then withdraws three
hundred dollars in cash
how much is left in his account so he's
starting with four thousand five hundred
twenty two dollars and eight cents let's
write that down four thousand five
hundred twenty two dollars and eight
cents and then he deposits he deposits
or he adds another eight hundred and
seventy five dollars and fifty cents so
he's going to add eight hundred and
seventy five dollars and fifty cents
when you deposit into an account you're
putting something into the count or
you're adding to the account so after he
adds that eight hundred seventy-five
dollars and fifty cents what does he
have so we go back to the penny spot or
we could view that as the hundredths a
penny is one hundredths of a dollar
eight let me switch colors we have eight
plus zero is 8 0 plus five is five have
the decimal right there 2 plus 5 is 7 2
plus 7 is 9 5 plus 8 is 13 put the three
down here and regroup the 1 or carry the
one one plus four is five so after the
875 dollar and 50 cent deposit he has
five thousand three hundred and
ninety-seven dollars and 58 cents then
he withdraws he withdraws three hundred
dollars in cash or he takes out three
hundred dollars so we'll have to
subtract that so then he withdraws three
hundred three hundred dollars and I just
added some trailing decimals at trailing
zeros after the decimal three hundred
dollars is the same thing as three
hundred dollars and zero cents and then
we subtract and then we can subtract 8
minus 0 is 8 5 minus 0 is 5 we have our
decimal right there 7 minus 0 is 7 9
minus 0 is 9 3 minus 3 is
zero and then five - nothing here is
five so he is left with in his account
five thousand ninety seven dollars and
fifty eight cents